نورنا الباحث العالم في الفضاء الدكتور
فاروق الباص دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
معنا نورتنا في مساء العرب
اهلا بك مساء الخير عليك وشكرا للمقدمه
الممتازه دي اهلا يا دكتور يطلق عليك يا
دكتور الكينج المصري يعني كنت ضمن فريق
ناسا استكشاف القمر حدثنا اكثر عن القمر
عن الثروات الموجوده في القمر وابرز
المعادن اكتشفت فيه
اهم حاجه عرفناها من رحلات للقمر بالنتيجه
للعينات اللي اخذها الرواد ان الارض
والقمر تكونا من نفس العناصر الكيميائيه
وتقريبا في نفس الوقت من الزمن يعني هم
الاثنين اخو يعني اخوات
وتكونوا من نفس المواد فدي كانت مهمه جدا
ان احنا نعرف دي ان القمر مجامل مكان اخر
لا ده جاي من نفس المكان اللي احنا جايين
منه من في المجموعه الشمسيه
دكتور فاروق انا اسمح لي
ابيك عن مواضيع تتعلق بالف
ضاء ولديك كويكب حتى في الفضاء
باسمه اليوم انا حابه اعرف دكتور فاروق
الانسان كيف يعيش اجواء رمضان طالما انت
ظاهر معنا اليوم ولاول مره في مسائل عربيه
على شاشه العربيه بدون اجواء رمضان
المبارك كيف يعيش دكتور فاروق اجواء رمضان
ومن حوله من اصدقائه واهل
كل سنه وانت طيبه وكل سنه والمشاهدين كلهم
طيبين احنا رمضان من ايام زمان قوي انا
والدي كان مدرس في الازهر الشريف فكان
بالنسبه لنا رمضان حاجه كبيره جدا واحنا
من الصغار وما زال عندي عند هذه الشعور
بنحتفل برمضان احتفال كبير جدا وبنسعد به
خالص والحمد لله انا بعرفهم لان احنا
تقدر تعمل اعمل مفاهيمك الحمد لله احنا
وبنسعد وبنهيص في رمضان زي ما الناس كلها
بتهيز طيب دكتور كنت عام 1969 بالقرب مني
وهو يحضر لاول رحله استكشافيه على القمر
كيف كان الشعور وقتها ولماذا لا نشاهد
اليوم او لنعيش رواد فضاء اخرين يكتشفون
القمر
والله كنا في ذلك اليوم
مرعوبين رعب كبير جدا احنا فسرنا كل ما
قلنا عليك لناسه
بالنسبه للمواقع الهبوط وبالنسبه للحته
اللي احنا اخترناها عشان اكل له 11 لنيل
متاكدين انها مستويه كليه وتماما واحنا ما
نعرفش
خرايط احنا
على سطح القمر ما نعرفش وبعدين قلنا ان
السفينه مش هتغرز
متاكدين قلنا قلنا اشياء كثيره جدا ما
كناش نضمنها ميه في الميه كانت يعني دكتور
فاروق بالعاده احنا في الحياه
ما بتزعجنا امور صغيره جدا وبنعمل منها
قصه كبيره اليوم لما الانسان بيكون
بالفضاء بشوف الارض من منظور صغير جدا وهو
بعيد جدا هل تتغير فلسفه الانسان ورؤيته
في الحياه هل شعرت بذلك دكتور
لان مثلا هم بيطلعوا من السفينه وهم
بيلفوا عينين الامر عشان يجيبوا
الفيلم من الكاميرا اللي هي بره السفينه
فبيفتح الباب شباك بتاعها وبيطلع في
الفضاء انا لا لا لا انسى ابدا
الفرد وورد تم فتح الباب وطالع على يجيب
البتاعه باص فوق وبس وبعدين بيقول لي
الثواب بتاع السما سواد رهيب انا عمري ما
كنت افكر اني هذا السواق وبعدين النجوم لا
بنشوفها دي ده نقط نقط رفيعه جدا بعيده
جدا يا خبر ده سبحان الله على نعمه ده
حاجه الواحد يرتعش لما يبص عليه انا
يعني
كاني
[موسيقى]
مربوط فيها لمده عده دقائق وابص كده من
فوق
للاسف دائما الوقت دا شكرا الباحث في
العالم في الفضاء الدكتور فاروق الباز نور
شكرا جزيلا لك رمضان كريم